Nhật năng là gì? Nhật năng là tổn năng được nông học của rất cả các phân tự tố tạo liên vật.
Công như thế nào? Hỉ hưởng kết năng là bằng tổn đồng năng của rất cả các phân tự.
Chứ trong vật? Nhưng mà là các phân tự trong vật chuyển động vốn rồi.
Với một tốt bộ, nào đây, thì nó sẽ có lộ năng.
Bộ phân tự, vậy tổn đồng năng của rất cả các phân tự tố tạo liên vật thì kể đó.
Là, Nhật năng là dễ đó là dễ năng được chứ nào? Bây giờ châu hành vật.
À bằng vật nơi tiếp xúc nhau, nếu như tổn của bật, à, mạnh lưới nó hêm như tổn của bật nơi.
Thì, Nhật năng sẽ chuyển tự vật à, sau bật nơi.
Nhật năng là Nhật năng sẽ chuyển tự vật à, sau bật nơi.
Cái phật nơi năng từ vật à chuyển sân bật nơi.
Thì hay bật tiếp xúc nhau, thì kể đó gọi năng nhật nơi.
Nhật nơi năng là phân năng nơi mà bật nơi nhận được của bật à.
Quả bật à, bật à, bật nơi ngọt chuyển sân bật, bật bệnh.
Được chứ nào, Nhật nơi năng số nó phân nhận năng chuyển từ vật nơi sân bật tiếp xúc nhau.
Chuyển chuyển tự rau.